[Music]
the one reality reality we must see the
Oracle I am the Oracle oh yeah
a homeowner surveillance video catches a
mailman urinating on his front porch
yeah Chinese mailman
well is this roses tournament right
known and the sheet on profits damn they
got some barbecue what did they do to
piss this mailman honk and Memphis has
postman they don't know it's that
they're saying that they recently moved
there and so like the other front their
front porch is in fast speech pause yeah
friends I'm gonna play a video for you
guys this separation boy you see him
take a piss yeah wow that's a pretty big
porch that's a big ass [ __ ] I always
wanted that arch with the vines wrapped
around it's like you're going into a
secret garden
it makes me think of like the UK I
feeling all the house
here we go he didn't waste any time
[Music]
hope you like that wow he's just going
while he's like drunk man is that water
lime from him yeah cuz his dick still
out soon as he started walking up the
steps he whipped it out in sarpy maybe
he really did he all over himself when
he does that he does a little bit cuz
he's walking forward yeah that's smart
and then he's like touching all the mail
too yeah it's cool that you start doing
this job though you put her in the bill
that's responsible you're looking at
this the wrong way he's so busy that he
didn't want to stop and go like he ate a
bathroom or anything like that he just
kept going and working that's that's a
hard worker well how come he just let it
drizzle everywhere but why the peeing on
someone else because I think okay so
like I always have to pee or [ __ ] really
bad right
I almost shat in in there bushes I get
this feeling right so it's here that he
hates this guy or it's embarrassing to
pee like to look like you're peeing so
he's like in front of the house and he's
peeing in the bushes or on the side so
you could get caught doing the obvious
it's more obvious but if you just whip
your dick out and pee as you're walking
up there you pee all over yourself the
crazy thing is that you relate to this
guy cuz nobody else could ever think
about anything relatable to this human
being I know it makes sense yeah it's
just a little bit up here a little bit
oh I mean like a little bit of pee will
dry up a little bit you never peed on
yourself come on now he was wearing
gloves so he didn't really have to get
any yeah I'm talking about the little
bit of pee on your pants just a little
bit no I got this song stuck in my head
wiggle so did he hate these guys they
just moved in cuz I feel like if you
really wanted to pee and you want to
respect them you could just pee in a
bottle right you don't have to pee like
right so what if they don't have like
what if he doesn't have a
he could pee while he's driving out the
[ __ ] that would be more respectful water
is like hell yeah it's just like Proctor
I peed in a bottle just like you hmm
you're right there's a lot of pee it's
way more than just this little thing
especially we really need a PA you
stopped your stream I had to do this
thing because you know the Tesla Auto
drives and [ __ ] pinches so I had to
literally with all my might and it's
right off I had well I have a bunch of
these disappear okay while the car was
going yeah but the table's autograph
because I imagine that police report if
you got no crash what were you doing so
that you weren't paying attention
it was so [ __ ] dope auto pilot is
[ __ ] dope but I literally filled it
up dangerous and then I filled up
another one - yeah
it was unreal because when you say do we
really Pete that much you peel off it's
a lot were you proud of yourself
I was just like that's a man [ __ ] no it
wasn't like that I was just shocked I
was like parts right we do peel that's
the first thing I thought about you for
thinking about this now if we pee that
much yeah you should try some pie I
don't know how I would aim unless I get
that yeah exactly the company just
painted something it's you can't just
suffocate it like you can't stuff it in
there like a [ __ ] rag put around it I
don't know where the hole is oh it's not
like pull this game back and get a
mirror in it oh it's not obvious yeah
it's like this like what about this dead
wood beep eating here this covers a
whole I was very proud of myself though
just because the water the pee was so
clear there's so much water
it didn't really smell the drank it no I
did not know about heard you could drink
it three times if you need a survival no
but like would you just because you're
so curious you always like love finding
[ __ ] out about your own piss would you
if you piece like super clear would you
drink it I might smell it also what I
found out is Rp it's really really hot
oh yeah
yeah you're hot is like maybe you eat
the green [ __ ] are they sir Malthus it's
hot though you never peed on yourself
you know what in 97 you know a 97 degree
weather day feels like [ __ ] you know
what a 98 degrees sounds like yeah I'm
saying no you so you don't know you lied
I peel myself all the time
wait I do promise cherish you church for
the rest of my life you waited so uh to
say this to you 98 degrees I back you up
thank you but that's what you to hold me
don't bro there's a more famous song I
don't remember that one
yeah they were yeah they did 100 history
x1 sounds pretty good don't be so dumb
if they did the soundtrack for American
History X yeah anyway so this Milky was
it was nothing it was he in his Nick
Nicky JC his brother I don't know why I
know this I wasn't even was it yeah JC
sounded ok which one is the one sounds
weird
yeah anyways dude there's a bangers dope
another one I forgot one say made me I
like the Christmas album oh I like the
crispiness
they just said Chris silent night they
probably did I know I know that they did
though because I actually bought that
[ __ ] cuz I love Christmas your nice
little town of Bethlehem homey
my favorite Christmas one is is no doubt
I was all good it is what there's a punk
version of a Christmas song yeah they do
their own though like it's not a
Christmas carol or whatever like they
did their own song Oh like originals yes
original ska Christmas yes Christmas
song right now I want to know what
happened at this post man I'm still like
trying to put my finger on the 98 degree
song that was like very popular there's
my everybody
those fools did that
that's [ __ ] I hope they sing it like
[ __ ] Pavarotti and [ __ ] Angela was
singing it and then Dwight was like yeah
how come every boy band is always one
dude that looks way older than everyone
else
Oh was it Joey fat one yeah joint fat
one yeah I felt so bad in 90 degrees
they just do with the goatee he has like
a popular thing I think his name was
good no no not 90 degrees sorry that's
Backstreet Boy there's always one to go
to yeah he looks all for one okay
I don't know all for one oh yeah what
song did they have I swear right I'll be
there
I thought there are boys to man for a
long time
cuz Woody's download music from my
Napster she always mislabel the [ __ ] out
of it so I thought that was Boyz II Men
and then I have got corrected did I
[ __ ] love those old R&B jams doll yup
though that should always gets me my
[ __ ] feels man are there any more boy
bands there's a live one what happened
to her he lost his job
no I mean there's so the USPS a Tony
Tony Tony they said that they would look
into what took place and look into
there's footage I know they said they're
gonna investigate the actions
their letter carrier and that that
behavior doesn't reflect their values
well that's uh so that's that's all I do
in postal who knows that's that
that's also a Tupac I bet he's so
gangster well you guys are talking about
singers you called it thanks a lot mom I
was doing such a good job
well you guys are talking about singers
and R&B singers not so anyway this girl
heard he was k.michelle she's from Love
& Hip Hop Hollywood my show her video of
like her doorbell thing went viral
because you'll see right now I'll play a
video they did I don't know I've seen
this I've seen she ring the doorbell
it's a little white girl like what the
but didn't she start shaking it yeah now
when people started to do this yeah that
was going around for a while
neighborhood looks ballin as but in the
funny part is the captions go there the
caption says I don't know who this lady
is that keeps ringing my doorbell every
day we don't want none of what you're
selling I had to be the voice of reason
she didn't know it was her wherever I am
at for my phone I don't play about
privacy on my house don't disrespect my
house a Little Bo Peep Little Bo Peep
don't come back either
hashtag fat thank God for the ring
security doorbell I know I know when
there is any motion on my property
I'm not mad though I was playing with
her I was in tears laughing I didn't
know where the voice of coming
that [ __ ] was funny how she was like
twerk it she just ran through a little
golf cart and went artery making that
video - it was pretty funny then
whenever a kid just do dumb [ __ ]
she probably think they were watching
like live why should I buy oh they'll
see this later in Hawaii I realized how
old I am because I'm not current with
the times of what is considered too
revealing him not right so you know all
the bikinis know there's ah yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh excuse me miss
thirteen-year-old better cover that [ __ ]
up so I thought stand on her and [ __ ]
but I didn't know what became like like
it's like super revealing you see the
thongs or like straight-up butt cheeks
out like everything yo really uh 13-year
old [ __ ] girl so I was like confused
I was like yellow man put the [ __ ] back
in young lady what the [ __ ] are you
doing probably like 16 and you just
think they're 13 it doesn't matter how
about young I know but like it's a beach
town like it's been like that I grew up
in a beach laughs it's a beach town
that's part of their culture
Oh about used to that [ __ ] maybe because
people of La are a little bit more
Nimrod that [ __ ] but like it threw me
off cuz I was like sure no after on an
island like everyone's just in a
swimsuit all the time I never seen so
many bully holes in my life Dan's very
house everywhere it was like what the
[ __ ] is going on dude but it does get
skip you're in skimpier yeah it's just
gonna be pasties in the future
[Music]
[Music]